If you’re an entrepreneur
you can’t quit.
You can’t throw in the towel
It’s going to be tough.
It’s going to be one of the hardest things
you’ve ever done in your life
you’re going to doubt yourself
you’re going to wonder why you don’t go back and get a job
but you can’t quit
because starting a business
takes time.
Even if you model success
even if you’re the smartest person in the world
it still takes time.
I need you to make sure that you’re around
when that success comes.
Something you do right now may take a year before it comes back
and that momentum grows.
I need you to make sure you’re still here.
You can’t quit.
Milton Hershey
who started the Hershey Chocolate Company
he started his business when he was 18 years old
Philadelphia, he borrowed a $100 from his aunt
because he had no money to start up
and he started in caramels
and he worked 15, 16 hours a day.
He’d make the caramels at night
and then he’d sell them on the streets during the day.
The business in Philly failed.
So he moved to Chicago
and did the same thing
and that failed.
He moved to New Orleans and did the same thing
And he moved to New York, tried it up again
and one day he got robbed on the streets of New York.
He lost all his inventory.
He had to close down the business
and return home to Philadelphia.
He had spent 6 years building these businesses
in different states
and they all failed.
He came back home to his family
and they disowned him.
They said, “You’re a failure.
You’re not part of our family anymore.
You’re not meant to be an entrepreneur."
And so the only place he could stay
was at the house of one of his former employees, Henry.
And Henry gave him a place to stay
and a little bit of money to keep going
because Milton Hershey had a new idea for a business.
He wanted to get into chocolates.
People said he was crazy
like, “Hershey, this isn’t for you.
You’re not meant to be an entrepreneur.
You’ve worked 15, 16 hours a day for 6 years
and you just had 4 failures.
Go do something else.
Go get a job.”
But he couldn’t do it.
He couldn’t quit. He knew it was in his blood.
He had to go after it.
Chocolate at the time was only for the rich people
and he had discovered a machine that could make it affordable
for everybody to do and to consume.
So he started chocolate
and the rest is history.
He stuck around
so he could achieve his success
even when people didn’t believe in him
even when he had failure after failure after failure.
He lost everything
he lost his family
but he kept going.
He didn’t quit.
I know it’s tough
I know it’s hard as an entrepreneur.
You may doubt yourself every day
wonder if you should stop
but just when the times are toughest
when it’s darkest around you
you have to go one more day.
You can’t quit.
If you’re following your passion
and you’re helping people
you can’t quit.
The light is around the tunnel.
It’s there.
I promise you.
Even if you can’t see it now it’s there.
And you have to take that one more step
go one more day
so you can achieve it.
Good luck.